[Musique]
j'ai entendu parler qu'on pouvait
potentiellement sortir du chemin de
l'abattoir des poules dit de réforme qui
a 18 mois sont plus assez pondeuses pour
pour l'industrie en fait de l'oeuf mais
qui pondent encore pendant quatre cinq
ans et qu'on peut récupérer plus pas
très cher donc du coup je m'étais
renseigné pour moi départ auprès d'un
organisme qui était une association qui
est devenu entreprises maintenant qu'ils
s'appellent poule pour tout ce qui est à
l'habitude de faire ce genre de
sauvetage entre guillemets je leur dis
moi j'ai une association
environnementale
peut-être que je peux me faire le relais
de vos initiatives ici dans mon coin
dans les yvelines
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas des poules de ce qu'on
appelle les dépouilles de chair donc
l'idée ce n'est pas de les manger
en fait j dc en vain de les garder à la
maison et de les mettre dans un
poulailler puis voilà d'avoir des
offrait régulièrement donc ça représente
environ 70 80 familles voilà du
territoire en fin des aventures
le camion arrive se posent sur le
parking de nos amis gamm vert et et
voilà moi je l annonce du nom des gens
ils seront tous maison tous frais payés
leurs animaux donc donc à l'annoncé de
leur nom il dit avec leurs cartons ou
leurs contenants ça peut être une caisse
de chats de chiens ce qu'ils veulent de
transport on leur met leur poule est et
leurs parts les installer tranquillement
chez eux ensuite